a protest in downtown las vegas as  family of jorge gomez demand justice for  the 25 year old now he was shot and  killed by police during a black lives  matter protest some two years ago today  he hasn't received any justice  for two years nothing at all the  steve wilson never indicted the officers  and i just think it's time that people  take it to the streets and just keep on  applying pressure  gomez was shot by four metro officers in  2020 police say gomez raised a gun at  them but the family says surveillance  video shows he did nothing wrong those  officers were not wearing body cameras  no charges were filed against police